[Music]
in germinator news submitted by Tesla
owner a new technology could kill 99.9%
of the deadly germs in the air 99.999
what can kill 99 a mutant a new
technology why would you want that well
not necessarily new it's just that this
this is way like they're using this
technology is new so they're sterilizing
the air but that means they're killing
the good bacteria so they've always like
people have always wanted to find out
ways to disinfect the care that's so
there's like those air purifiers now
it'll be nice in Vegas I wouldn't have
gotten bronchitis in the air that's
exactly why I thought you know great
because you guys can relate so they're
saying that there's this new study that
suggests that non thermal plasma which
is a cool gas made up of electrically
charged particles could inactivate
airborne viruses and provide sterile air
thank God for thermal plasma yeah
non-thermal we need non thermal plasma
don't we need to get sick Abbi yeah well
it's just that there's so many outbreaks
going on that we're trying to like less
like measles and oh well that's because
of the anti-vaxxers [ __ ] [ __ ] up
maybe that's a way that our universe is
like whoa this [ __ ] planet is getting
too heavy for me to carry we need to get
rid of some people that's basically why
we have plagues that's true or wars its
nature balancing it it's a balance
probably doesn't get me in the mix do
you know me yeah don't hurt me please
I'm a good guy yeah yeah I'm guess why
that last [ __ ] Avengers movie when
Thanos got rid of like half the
population I was like I think you got it
right I think it makes sense that more
people should be born gay because then
the procreation level will go down yeah
but they're adopting and so they're
helping but like yeah maybe not
surrogates but yeah daunting that's true
we're gonna travel populated yeah
there's somebody have a theory about
that [ __ ] too
there's like a theory word because of
like overpopulation there's been like
more homosexuality that's how like the
it makes sense it does it happens in the
animal kingdom so my mom would say
because all my boyfriends were shorter
than me and I was like why am I tried to
- our guy she goes oh it's just nature
balancing it's like if it's two tall
people you're only gonna create even
taller people so she's like you know we
got to just keep it like say that the
young being and his wife it wasn't an
attraction rate it wasn't it oh that was
his parents like the government put them
two together oh I don't know about that
but that's interesting I heard that oh
maybe young Yami's parents the
government to create a really won't be
surprised because Russia did that [ __ ] -
are they yeah they're so tall I didn't
see any tall I felt really tall in
Austria your brother says an Australian
woman I guess like yes you're very tall
to me Icelandic [ __ ] they're
[ __ ] mute yeah it's not relations no
we're all gonna stand out so I mean I
saw a lot more tour in Swedes oh yeah if
you go with the locals there's a lot of
big guys like our you know our buddy
Matt Vincent mm-hmm so he wasn't about a
bunch of Icelandic like locals and he
was sitting in a bathtub and he looked
like Bobby Lee like next to David [ __ ]
look like a child and Matt Vinson is a
big [ __ ] yeah our tour guide
said from there like he would would be
on the bus talking to you guys like this
is he so big no he wasn't that big but
he said that most of the people we're
gonna encounter aren't even native to
Iceland yeah did you know that they
weren't always that big yeah we've many
museums where all this stuff's like
really small but the Norwegians
did you know that the Vikings and all
that happened is saying the whole world
yeah they just have the gene that helps
them grow bigger and all that human
growth hormone because for the most of
the world's history people weren't
getting enough nutrients so they weren't
getting to the max of what their body
and genetics yeah cuz even Asians are
getting bigger now when you know they've
been typically very small tiny hmm but
their genetics are changing and how do
you explain the northern
agents like they're really tall I mean
there's probably like genetic
dispositions but I think the
is releasing the potential to biology
that like for example I think a taller
asian that you might see with a higher
protein diet might be like 6-1 6-2 6-3
but the nice landok is like six six six
eight seven oh my gosh yeah well yeah
this whole purifying the air thing is
pretty cool
I don't like it we're always trying to
sterilize everything and that's what's
causing a lot of [ __ ] well so
according to WHO you know World Health
Organization are very small yeah
according to WHO the flu results in more
than three million cases of severe
illness per year and about two hundred
and ninety thousand to six hundred and
fifty thousand deaths and they're saying
that the most lethal pandemic was of the
influenza virus was the Spanish flu h1
h1
I mean h1n1 in 1918 through 1919 that it
it affects infected about a quarter of
the global population and caused more
than 40 million deaths no team is we
haven't had a epidemic in a long time
we're long overdue
well I remember there was a time where
every year was like a new epidemic and I
remember h1n1 was part of it too you
remember the bird flu yeah I went to
Asia during the bird food yeah sorry
yeah a severe cancer story syndrome my
friend got stars and then he had to be
in those isolation things at the airport
and that fool was in the hospital bed
like this and then his family took a
picture of him from the outside oh my
god yeah he's alive yeah that's scary I
know and then you know the during the
bird flu me my friend went to China
during that time and we went in the ate
KFC yeah it was delicious
why cuz it was infected man aster yeah
cuz we were just like bucket I'm a live
life on the wild side and no one there
was talking about bird food no one there
was scared of anything no mad cow
disease that was in that Airport that
was in UK I was terrified of Ebola when
I found out about a bowl yeah I was like
yeah sure could happen to you that [ __ ]
was instapoll a spinach Zika doesn't
scare me as much because that just
affects your baby if you get pregnant
but like a bowl of virus like you like
internally combusts or some [ __ ] like
you start bleeding out your eyeballs and
stuff it's crazy there's a lot of
dangerous diseases oh yeah and we're
long overdue [ __ ] that scares me is like
um when people go into like jungle or
whatever and then you swim in the ocean
or like in the river or sort of yeah
there's a book and parasite that's the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] oh yeah oh the life it
controls your brain and makes you into a
zombie that's it it's all over Hawaii
[ __ ] don't go in the fresh water
oh dude they crawl into your [ __ ]
body system and and then they crawl into
your brain and then they [ __ ] control
you through your brain what do they make
you do breakdance that'll be kind of
cuckoo the dead yeah very wavy did the I
don't know I feel like life is just a
crapshoot like you can't live being
afraid of everything the parasite for
crazy cat ladies that comes from the oh
yeah yeah oh really and it makes me it
makes them into the crazy cat ladies
where they're like that crazy like no
women can't [ __ ] with the capsule poo
yeah when I was pregnant there's I
that's it I think that one's a kitty
litter thing there's something a lady in
the litter yeah I mean the mixture boat
there's a about what it was but they're
just like don't clean out your kitty
litter box like that's bad yeah for the
powdery kind of litter right yeah every
kind of litter yeah there's different
kinds mm-hmm what about what happens at
the crazy cat you collect a lot of cats
of [ __ ] yeah you know it's yeah it's
like that and the you know these like he
talked everything like these like that's
not just some crate that is a crazy cat
lady parasite thing Oh
get rid of it there's a permanent I
don't think so where were the crazy cat
men probably I never really meant crazy
cat yeah
I mean my grandpa collects cats but he
never talks to them like that he had a
lot of um well he fosters kittens now
but he at one point when I would go over
there he'd have like twelve cats Oh have
you seen the cat the kitty parade
there's this guy that walks and then
there's these little kitties there's
like kittens that's what we call it at
my house Liberty because my cats follow
me everywhere no and so Steve always
calls it the kiddie parade huge funny
creatures because Franklin always
follows me and then Joe always follows
Franklin so Joe doesn't give a [ __ ] if
rain was not there he doesn't follow me
but but if Frank was following me he's
falling for you always shadow yeah and
then Franklin's like my shadow yeah and
they love each other yeah I see them
they're so cute homosexual lover
plutonic I don't know I don't ask them
all animals are kind of gay baths and
stuff are these fixed yeah I know
because my my two doggies are lesbians
mmm they hump the [ __ ] out of each other
all the time
they wrassle all the time and like get
each other in missionary and stuff all
animals are kind of gay no t-shirt all
animals are kind of gay we're all kind
of gay damn there's so many diseases in
the world like if you try to think of
them every single day it's like music
there's like just so much yeah music
there's like so there's like yeah
there's so many I don't even be you
could have a disease for every [ __ ]
day of the year and you still don't
cover all the diseases yeah that's so
many disease yes you are David you're
influenza that one sickness that we just
all had recently didn't have it that's
crazy because that [ __ ] was
contained cats it was going around
everybody going to [ __ ] die dude
especially hit nationwide I've never
been sick that for that long in a
long time like I don't remember last
time I was sick for six days me too
like I was in a coffin me too yeah yeah
it was like a it was like something that
turned into bronchitis yeah but I had
like a I had like a migraine and a fever
of like three days it wouldn't go I was
like oh [ __ ] I might have to go to
hospital yep
yeah but then he started subsiding a
little bit I had a migraine I never had
urged to go to the hospital and toss in
Vegas and I was like oh [ __ ] this is
really bad yeah me you guys put a whole
couple days go away all night [ __ ] I
can't even breathe right now yeah that's
crazy see if we had this I know MGM
install it I don't know about that
sometimes being sick helps me realize
I'm alive that's true and it makes me
not stress like cuz stress takes over my
entire life and then when I'm sick I
literally can't stress cuz like I'm just
trying to keep myself alive and I want
to hang out with people though I think
being sick reminds me you need a rest
boy yeah oh thank you very much exactly